what is the missing number 100 101 102
103 104 105 106 is the missing number
and then we go one hundred seven hundred
eight hundred nine hundred ten so the
missing number is 106 that's the number
after 105 and before a hundred and seven
let's keep going what is the missing
number well if I started a hundred the
next number is going to be a hundred and
one and then we go to 100 and 200 and
300 four we go keep going this is
exciting what whole number comes right
before hundred and five
well what whole number comes right
before five well four so what number
comes right before a hundred and five
what's going to be 104 if you're
counting after 100 you get a hundred
hundred one hundred two hundred three
hundred four and then you go to a
hundred and five alright so they want us
to figure out what the missing number is
and we see that they're counting one two
three all the way up to ten and then
here they're going from eleven to twenty
they're counting all the way up to 120
but there's a missing square here so
this is the number that is one larger
than 118 and one less than 120 well if I
was counting I'd go 100 1,100 1,200
1,300 1,400 1,500 1,600 1,700 1,800 19
and then 120 19 is before 20 so 119 is
going to be before 120 and 19 is after
18 so the number after 118 is going to
be 119 let's check our answer
let's do one more of these well we've
done these a lot already what number is
missing right after seven comes eight so
right after 107 comes 108 and then 109
and a hundred and ten